und geht beim lügen mal was schief dann
entschuldige dich damit die schuld ich
nicht trifft und dass es einfach nur
eine zerberstende leihen weil diese
vorlage mit geo als nazi das ist eine
lüge war und das ist dass sie sich da
vertan hat bei dem bei den madison bei
der punch ein dass es einfach
sonnensonde steilvorlage für forschung
gewesen und das darauf eingehe darauf
habe ich nur so gewartet dass sowas
kommt deswegen als ich finde vor james
lyons alter die zerbersten alles
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge survival games eine
folge auf dem device server ich glaub
survival games 6 war das und ich
kommentiere das ganze gerade nach weil
ich finde wenn ich so zweifeln
heimspiele kann ihn nie so gut reden das
einzige gut reden kann es mega projekt
enthalten sieg aber ich hatte halt bock
auf survival games die runde ist
megageil ich werde nachher zweiter und
habe sogar noch zwei diamant schwerter
aber ich bin halt mit einem anderen
typen noch um gelaufen und wir haben
halt beiden diamant sperrten die gleiche
ausrüstung und ihr wisst dass ich dann
im pvp trotzdem halte weil der harte
übelste bogen skills und also die runde
ist auf jeden fall geil das thema über
das ich mir sprechen möchte ist julians
blog betteln und die manipulation
beziehungsweise ein paar sachen die mich
dorthin wo ich mich so fragen hey so
nach dem motto und zwar geht es um das
jbw king finale zwischen fortune und
spongebob
ich habe dieses ganze bettel nicht so
heftig verfolgt ich hab das jetzt
gedruckt seit dem finale von spongebob
gegen joe und da habe ich den aus
meinungs- video erst mal gesehen was ich
total mit sympathisiere halbwegs
zumindest und andererseits habe ich dann
halt also bis halt was andererseits
außerdem habe ich dann halt angefangen
ein paar battle videos zu gucken und so
was alles vom jbbl battle turnier weil
davor habe ich immer war treuer vbt koka
und dass er zurzeit nicht jetzt habe ich
gedacht kommt schon mal bei jbb vorbei
und das metalfest man sich übels
unorganisiert und zwar alles aber das
wissen ja die meisten schauen und die
meisten gucken dieses battle auch
eigentlich nur den spaß das sieht man
auch dass wenn man mal auf julians blog
battle kanal geht ihr seht auch alle
links in der beschreibung auch die
videos über die ich gleich reden werde
wenn man mal auf newmans blog werden auf
den kanal geht sieht man schon dass die
klicks die videos mit den meisten klicks
wenn man auf größte beliebtheit bei
videos klickst klickt sieht man schon
dass das ganz klar spongebobs ist der
bei vielen videos einfach mal über eine
million klicks hat und andere runden die
ich an sich sogar besser fand ich möchte
jetzt keine namen was ich besser fahren
weil sonst werde ich wieder nur geredet
von allen anderen werden gehen dann
einfach unter weil halt alle nur spaß
neue runde
ich werd angerufen
an spaß neue runde da gehe ich doch
jetzt direkt mal hin und mach da
blablabla ich schaue mir das an die
ganzen kleinen kinder feiern das
natürlich deswegen ist das erst mal so
eine sache dass dieser spongebobs gar
nicht so die heftigsten skills hat das
muss man erst mal so sagen ob das ganze
jetzt also er hat keine häftlings gilt
das einzige was er habe was er hat ist
automeile bearbeitung und so weiter also
genauso wie beim asiaten halt damals
falls ihr das überhaupt noch kennt und
die sache ist halt die bei ihm jetzt ich
möchte mich jetzt mal genau das finale
beziehen und zwar packe ich euch die
beiden links in der beschreibung von
fortune gegen als bond spaß also spaß
ist er sieger des junis blog battle 2013
und spongebob fortune von 2012 deswegen
peking finale der beat ist bei spongebob
besser und das video spongebobs besser
das war bei den asiaten auch immer so
dass damals war die beats teilweise
gleich weil man in den vorigen runden
die beats sind halt gleichzeitig muss
man hat die gleich mitnehmen und der
beat ist definitiv bei spongebob geiler
und die videobearbeitung auch das muss
ich sagen da finde ich hat sich vor
tieren überhaupt keine mühe um das
äußeres gemacht und zwar hat vor
ziemlich schlechte location der hat nur
seinen strand genommen und will dann da
wo im hintergrund aber industrie zu
sehen ist was alles und will damit so
bikini bottom so ein bisschen darstellen
tätig so so verwegen schwammkopf petrics
und seestern so am strand und was alles
wissen und die videoqualität an sich ist
auch einfach übel suisse also die
location sind so schlecht da steht er
vor einem brunnen dann steht einer
hamburger innenstadt bei nacht auf einer
brücke über sondern sondern weiter hoch
befahrene straße und
da bei diesem dings bei diesem komischen
strand da also locations für kaká hat
gar keine location der steht nur einmal
vor seinem flugzeug und ein mal vor so
zwei heftigen autos das sind halt zwei
locations glaube ich aber hat er noch
mehr ich weiß es nicht berichte ich mich
wenn ich etwas falsches sage aber
trotzdem findet diese location viel
geiler weil sich natürlich die
nachbearbeitung noch viel geiler gemacht
werden ich finde allerdings das fortune
deutlich bessere punch hat und damit
spongebobs sowas von zerbersten und
darauf konstanz an bei einem battle nur
das ist der job blog betteln da kommt es
mehr auf da kommt auch auf video und so
was alles anders wird fast genauso
bewertet wie pan schleiz und rap technik
zu wenig dass ein bisschen blöd also die
bewertung an sich ist erst mal von grund
auf gut die prozente verteilung die
punkteverteilung für die einzelnen
kategorien ist allerdings dermaßen
schlecht und die verteilung von julie
unter fürst auch so scheiße zum beispiel
manche punches was den auch schon gesagt
hat manche punch ist wie zb ich [ __ ]
deine mutter und so was alles das wird
zum beispiel dann als punch gewertet das
hat eigentlich so ich [ __ ] deine mutter
das hat jeder von uns aber so die
heftigsten sachen die übels
hintergründig sind wo wir die
hintergründe von den anderen rapper
erstmal herausfinden muss um dann darauf
zu waschen und zu dessen das wird dann
wieder nicht als punk speziell bei
giulia soll das verstehe ich nicht
wer sich aber dann irgendwie unter einer
decke mit ein paar rappen steckt und
dass alles so ein bisschen selbst
manipuliert naja sollte der
manipulations blog battle.net schon aber
egal das ist ein anderes thema ich finde
allerdings das forschen die deutlich
besseren punchlines hat und wenn julia
irgendwas anderes sagt dann komme ich
hin und führt ihn sein alter das kann
nicht sein dass das also ich war ab
seine bewertungen noch nicht gesehen
aber ich find's einfach fortune hat die
viel besseren partner als ich meiner der
hat zum beispiel ich sage jetzt erstmal
warten wie viel habe ich hier drei erst
mal und zwar deinem arm zieht den rocker
sowie die frau von granger uns also
wrote the train the rock johnson ist
edita übelste bodybuilder oder ich bis
die auf den bauch du willst es
wegwischen aber sag's team ist ja direkt
auf also ich mach das jetzt ohne flohen
ohne ihn welche web technik nicht liest
es nun vorerst ob das genau stimmt aber
ich habe mir die nase ein bisschen
irritiert weil er halt einen spongebobs
ist spongebob ist also ein schwamm oder
zum beispiel auch bei soviel löchern
weiß nicht welche sich als erstes [ __ ]
soll
wiener disco und so was alles übel
heftige sachen schon und das aller
zerbersten der auch wenn er einfach ein
video gemacht hätte mit dieser einband
schneiden dann hätte der schon direkt
gewonnen meiner ansicht nach und zwar
dieses mit dem finale hat spongebob jahr
gesagt koordination hat er dann bilder
gezeigt wo die angeblich bei seiner
rechten demonstrationen von der npd oder
irgendwie sowas dabei war und das waren
einfach nur bilder die ihm zu gesendet
wurden per facebook und die leute
einfach bearbeitet haben und einfach
tschüss kopf eingestellten weiland so
ähnlich aussah video und dann
entschuldigt dass damit habe ich schon
direkt in der klemme weil er halt
falsche sachen genommen hat ist genauso
wie wenn man sagt du brauchst eine fett
blablabla so fett absaugen damit du
irgendwie ein bisschen was reißt keine
ahnung irgendwie sowas das ist einfach
wenn man lieben ihren battle anwendet
nicht das an sich schon scheiße aber
dann entschuldigt er sich auch noch
dafür wo was er natürlich machen musste
aber jetzt steht da natürlich als pussy
dabei es sich fürs lügen entschuldigen
die so etwas gesagt und geht beim lügen
mal was schief dann entschuldigt du dich
damit die schuld ich nicht trifft und
dass das einfach nur eine zerberstende
leihen weil diese vorlage mit jo als
nazi das ist eine lüge war und das ist
dass es sich da vertan hat bei dem bei
dem mit dessen bei der bahn scheint dass
es einfach sonders steilvorlage für
forschung gewesen und dass er darauf
eingehe darauf habe ich nur so gewartet
dass sowas kommt deswegen als ich finde
vor james lyons alter die zerbersten
alles und spaß habe ich noch eine line
und zwar der ist total oberflächlich das
ist so schlechte punchlines du
verteidigten titel den du nicht mehr
verdient hast also ich weiß nicht oder
auch noch irgendwie sowas ja also
poliert seine glatze denken so ein
scheiß also ich weiß es nicht ich finde
das nicht heftig ich finde die punch ist
einfach bei ford schon viel besser
fortune hat natürlich die erfahrung und
es ist mir scheißegal wer hinter der
maske von spongebob setzt von mir aus
kann der of san diego oder kollege
aufsitzen oder halt weiß ja nicht wie
kennt keine ahnung ist mir auch egal
wenn natürlich alle wieder sagen hat
kann ja nicht wegen deiner kann nicht
kollegah sein
das wäre der beste grund unter einem
video steht leute überlegt doch mal das
kann ich cool dann guckt euch mal die
arme an
wer sagt denn dass kollege dahinter
stapelt all das kann doch sein dass die
mutter von kollege an den kostüm steckt
und dass kolleginnen rappt also wenn man
mich fragen würde würde ich sogar als
erstes sagen dass es kollegah ist und
farben ist dann halt patrick bzw spricht
dass ein bisschen das wird mir so als
plausibel klingen aber san diego auf
kleinsten also dass man dazu nur er ist
allgemein sehr sehr oberflächlich und so
was alles oder was ich mich zum beispiel
gefragt hat bei zwei minuten 12 als ich
habe erst hingeguckt und dann spongebobs
und dann auf allerbesten spaß bei zwei
minuten 12 könnte immerhin scrollen du
hängst wie thunfisch am angelhaken oder
irgendwie sowas also ich verstehe nicht
woher er das weiß weil das team hat so
was ähnliches gesagt in seiner hinrunde
und ich weiß nicht ob es passt irgendwie
schon die lyrics von von julien
irgendwie schon vorher bekommen hat oder
irgendwie sowas und julien hat ja auch
die lyrics in dem text von spot in dem
text von tune nicht angegeben zuerst
angegeben gehabt und dann irgendwie
wieder rausgenommen oder so und dann
zeigen ja wurden wir noch nicht
geschickt so nach dem motto so von wegen
dass er diese gerüchte dass ein bisschen
abweichenden sagen kann ja die wurde mir
nicht mehr geschickt dass er weitergeben
so nach dem motto keine ahnung also wie
gesagt manipulations turnier läuft auf
jeden fall bei julien sponge außerdem
teil eins kopiert wie zum beispiel
einmal deine mutter und geht zu karneval
als [ __ ] oder hals ein paar andere
sachen das war glaube ich mal von adi
oder irgendwie sowas keine ahnung habe
ich auf jeden fall schon mal hin wo
gerade allerdings was man besten spas
sagen muss es halt einfach das gebiet
besser ist dass videos besser und die
double time ist so zerbersten
die damit ein schnelles heftig alter
diesel einfach nur boshaft mit zettel
und zwar bei vierbeiner minute 4 gehts
los mit der double time und bei vier
minuten 44 bis vier minuten 58 jungen
diese stelle könnte ich mir als
klingelton machen als er das ist so
heftig da kriegt man gänsehaut da geht
an eine update ist man auf dem
bildschirm weiter dass es heftig dass es
heftige technik einfach nur das ist
richtig geil und die hoch bei sponge es
halt auch allgemein einfach krass also
finde ich keine ahnung ihr müsst euch
das selber alles anhören
die drinks sind wie gesagt eine
beschreibung bei tune ist der part vor
der hoch finde ich nur geil oder sagt es
war schwer etwas gemeinsam dieser
schützt uns bekannt gemacht doch der
unterschied im gegensatz zu di bleibe es
auch oder irgendwie sowas und tune halt
immer so unterschwellig zum nächsten
jahr
aber mir scheißegal unter der maske
steckt sondern niemals geweckt ist die
aufmerksamkeit auf weg und zwar aus
alles also seid nun auch auf jeden fall
der plattform ergänzt der tat vor der
hub ist bei tuner auf jeden fall
gänsehaut da wo der beetle ein leiser
gemacht wird und er halt einfach nur so
a cappella quasi spricht und die
hotspots ist einfach an sich krass
dieses sofa qualität finde ich
allerdings eben ein bisschen unnötig
naja ich weiß nicht was ich davon halten
soll von diesem ganzen battle for bisher
weiß man da sitzt ein vernünftiges jury
hinter dass es alles ganz normal
plausibel relativ genau entschieden und
da hat man experten und für julien ist
für mich weil sie nicht der kann zwar
gut analysieren aber ich find ich weiß
nicht was ich wem ich da noch glauben
soll und was und wie und blauen block
ich sympathisiere bei dieser runde auf
jeden fall mit fortune wenn es ums
äußere geht wenn es im video battle wer
wie die rap battle dann wird ganz klar
spongebobs gewinn weil die video und bei
nachbearbeitung und beat und rock und
damit haben alles krass aber von der
technik her bis fortune einfach nur wo
also vom bahnsteig so was alles deswegen
würde ich sagen hinrunde hat könnte
unentschieden seien aber finde ich hat
tune klar für sich entschieden ich weiß
nicht ob ich zurück und auch noch mal
sowas mache aber da wird ja die analyse
von julien kommen deswegen werde ich das
mit nadal sein lassen ich möchte nur als
auch mal meine meinung dazu gesagt habe
nämlich das aufregt dass überall dieser
hype ist wer steckt hinter der maske von
spongebob doch scheißegal alter micro
ist das auch so das ist doch scheißegal
entweder feiert die musik oder nicht
dass es da ganz egal wenn der mast
gesteckt und halt noch zu diesem turnier
weil sie nicht finde ich scheiß fertig
sind
ich glaube sogar dass du denn da so ein
bisschen unter der decke steckt mit
spongebob und irgendwie keine ahnung wer
das ist aber ist mir auch wie gesagt
egal wenn man mich fragen würde würde
ich sagen kollegah und farid bang dass
sie sich einen spaß erlaubt haben keine
ahnung würde ich schon irgendwie so
sagen aber sonst bin ich erst mal das
von dem video von spongebob würde ich
mir nur die hoch runter laden weil die
zerbersten oder halt abstelle 4 ab vier
minuten halten dann hat man so einen
geilen double time trax und park von
schloss bb king finale battle und
bettchen kann man sich einfach alles
geben wenn man battle rap schauer ist
dann weiß man doch ganz klar dass türen
das besser gemacht hat ihr seht jetzt
noch das gameplay ein bisschen weiter
das geht auf jeden fall noch sehr lange
ich werde den rest so nochmal in
schnellerer links machen nochmal in
schnellerer geschwindigkeit oder
nehme ich glaub ich hab das schon so
schnell gemacht dass es jetzt gleich zu
ende sein wird ihr mir hört jetzt auch
die musik ein bisschen lauter wenn es
euch gefallen hat und ihr meine meinung
teilt dann will ich mich auf jeden fall
über eine bewertung freuen
das wird mir dann auch mal zeigen also
wenn jetzt wirklich ein daumen hoch geht
das denn ihr genauso denkt wie ich dann
würde ich mich wesentlich sehr sehr
tolle band freuen damit ich das so
aussehen kann wie er darüber denkt
beziehungsweise schreibt mir ganz ganz
viele kommentare was er gemeint von
diesem battle denkt und dann würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns wieder heute abend
in the beast wo meine stimme allerdings
nicht aufgenommen wurde sondern nur von
face kämen aber habe ich ihn noch ein
vortrag vom video gemacht und dann
übrigens bin ich auf den us druckplatte
getreten aber das kommt erst morgen so
an alle die so weit gekocht haben
schreibt jetzt meine kommentare eure
meinung und schreibt mir einfach kombos
rein wenn ihr noch dran seid gerade
unter neuer viel spaß macht